right it's the question on everyone's
lips
the pm looking for inspiration on a
nursery visit in london
to launch a review into babies and
toddlers health
he has set out his roadmap to freedom
but
so many questions still about what our
new normal
will look like the headlines today
everywhere
are about having papers to go into the
pub is that the trade-off that we get to
ditch masks
and social distancing if we have
either a negative covered test or a
vaccine passport
to get into the pub i think it's it's
far too early to
draw any conclusion like that but just
to be clear you are considering that you
either will need a test
or a vaccination and proof of that to go
indoors
into a pub well past may the 17th well
all sorts of things are being considered
i really think it's a bit premature
uh to start talking about that so there
will be a role for certification but it
might just be for international travel
it could be for pubs
i i think we need to think carefully
about the issues as i've said before
there are lots of difficult issues
new coronavirus powers have proved today
in the commons
but the pm under pressure from his own
mps to explain what exactly he plans to
do with them
these are extraordinary provisions not
for normal times and they should be
expired at the earliest possible
opportunity
tyranny is a habit and the motions on
the order paper this evening
show that we haven't quite kicked the
habit
the danger is that government starts to
believe that these fundamental civil
liberties
belong to ministers to grant to us
or withhold they do not they belong as
of right
to british citizens the powers
underpinning the prime minister's
roadmap extended today
but with a rebellion from 35 of his own
back benches
there is growing frustration and anger
from his own mps
that while we know when we're going to
unlock we're still in the dark about
what that might actually look like
whitehall sources tell me
there will be a role for domestic
certification
be that proof of a covered jab immunity
or a negative covert test
but as for the details well it's still
under discussion
we're here more on covered certificates
and international travel plans on april
the 5th
until then the uncertainty is having a
real impact for businesses like this
in bristol if they say okay
where we've said it's going to open on
the 17th of may
but we think may is a bit doubtful but
we're going to say
from you know the 30th of may or the 1st
of june
and then that will be it that would be
good but this
not knowing is very difficult indeed
the prime minister has shown us his
sketch of a plan for the coming months
very soon it will be time to start
filling in the gaps
between sky news